- Now, before the philosophy of life,
we gonna get through that.
But we have to go back to the beginning
where this thing started to
get to really understanding
what life is really about.
When we come into this world,
we come into this world
believing what someone else
tells us cause we babies.
A woman wake up and say, I'm
your mother, I'm your father.
You really don't know that.
You just going by what they tell you.
So as you grow, if you have many children,
like if you got three or four kids,
and you got a younger one,
first mom and dad telling you what to do.
Then your brothers and sisters
babysit you and give you,
and tell you what to do.
And you have to remember,
all these people character
is different when they grow.
So when mom and dad tells you,
and your brother tells you
and your sister, your
older sister tells you,
may be a little different
from what mom and dad said
cause they done seen, they eyes been open.
They done grew, and they
done seen things differently
from what mom said and what dad said,
their outlook on life.
Then you go to your school teacher.
Then you go to your boss,
and he tells you, well,
we need to do this for the job,
and this is the way I want things did.
You might have experience
with that job and say, well,
I worked for a company, and we did it.
I'm the boss.
It's got to go my way.
You do it this way, now
you don't work here.
So by the time you do it like that,
you've worked him for 20, 30 years.
He got part of his character
installed in you, you know?
And so then you come up wanting things.
You see the bicycle
and the only thing that
makes you want it is,
dude, you see Jimmy with
that brand new bike?
Well, I want one of them.
Look at those new Jordans,
and you got a pair of Jordans
on your feet, but you want
the ones that look different.
I want a pair of them.
So as we go through life, we
starting wanting these things.
Then you want the drive
license and the car,
and I'm not saying this is wrong.
If you can sustain these kind of things
and you don't mind struggling
that, but they like babies.
You got to have the upkeep on them.
So, any kind of anguish we in our lives,
we cause that on ourself
by wanting so much.
Now you take a guy, I'm
not saying I'm better.
I'm homeless right out
here, like everybody else.
But you take a guy like me,
I've never had a drink
of liquor in my life,
never hit a crack pipe, never did crystal.
Never had a driver license.
Never had a phone.
Never went to school.
Never had a, really, house.
No brothers, no sisters, no wife and kids.
So a guy like that, he comes
up living life on life terms.
And as he, he might've wanted
these things, cause he human.
And we all want these things,
but once you determine
in your mind that you
cannot live without 'em,
or life is no good without 'em,
then this is where start
coming depression, suicidal.
Your wife left you and you
got child support, you know?
Now you listening to your home boy,
you go in a bar and you start
drinkin' and you have a drink
and it takes you away
from the reality of life.
And then you do, you
start doing your drug,
you start on your drug
run, and all these things
take you from reality of life.
But only one thing, the old saying,
what goes up must come down.
So when you get sober or
when you come off that drug,
the same problem exists.
But now, you couldn't fix it
then and you can't fix it now
and you keep doin' it.
Cause you listen to all your
friends, giving you advice.
And then by the time you
get 60 or 70 years old,
you say, who am I?
What is it that I really want to do?
Cause I did what my mama wanted me to do.
I did what my dad wanted me to do.
I did what my brothers wanted me to do.
I did what my school
teacher told me to do.
I did what my boss told me to do.
And then it came to my wife and my kids.
I had to live to please them.
I don't like this, and I don't like that.
The problem with wives and kids is that
even if you're married and you become one,
you really are four.
Because you have to live for your wife,
meet her demands and keep her happy,
but you still have a character of your own
on the way you feel and
the way you do things,
and this is where
arguments and fights start.
Well, I didn't know you were like that.
I told you then when we got
married, I didn't like that.
Well, you want me to change
my whole life to love you?
Well, see, this is what love is about.
Love is something so
powerful and so beautiful
that if you try to control
it or understand it,
just like it makes you feel
good, it'll make you feel bad.
Because I'm not real religious fanatic,
but if there is a god,
how can you understand
the power that god created, you know?
So, you, what is wrong
with love is is most people
be so busy trying to
understand it and control it
they never even settle down
to truly love each other.
You hear women say, well,
why do you love me so much?
Or men, why do you love me so much?
Why does there have to be a reason?
For instance, me and you met.
I don't even, I don't really know you,
and you don't really know me.
You know what I told you, but
when get around each other,
we comfortable, and we
smile witheach other
like we been knowing
each other all our lives.
And we got people, we been
knowing each other all our lives,
I'm sure on both sides, that
we don't care to be around.
We have met people we don't
care to have them around us.
Well you and me, somebody
you met a week ago,
and you hit it off with them
good, and you like this person,
and you don't mind being
around them, and hey,
he or she got a good
disposition about they self.
They know how to smile.
They not stressful.
And they don't have a
lot of hangups in life.
Now, we all human, so I
fall sometime in a category
to where we lose things
and we gain things.
Everything gonna come and go in life.
You're not gonna have anything forever.
The only things you will have
that you have to buy more,
that you gonna have to make a payment on,
your clothes and your food.
Everything else, if you get a phone,
you gotta make that payment every month.
If you get a car, you gotta
make that payment every month.
You gotta buy his gas and so on.
And I'm not saying that's wrong.
That's good cause toys
and nice things in life
is the human way.
But the problem is, is when
you decide you can't have that
or make that payment, you know?
Your life is not over, and
most people think life is over.
Like, if you see a person burn,
their whole house burn down,
my house burned down, I lose everything.
But you didn't lose your life.
What if you'd have been in
that fire and lost your life?
So you can get all this again, see?
But you can't get your
life back again, you know?
And so, my thing is this here.
I used to listen to three song,
and now I listen to five songs.
And I always walk around
singing these songs.
The one song I'd always say
♪ Baby, don't wear it ♪
♪ Cause every little
thing gonna be all right ♪
And then the first song
I used to love is say
♪ Ain't got nowhere to live ♪
Your wife done broke, I
tell you your wife say,
♪ Your wife done left you ♪
♪ You're broke, ♪
♪ But don't worry, be happy ♪
You know?
And then, they had two songs that come out
about few months ago.
The one that says
♪ Everybody ain't my partner ♪
♪ Everybody ain't my friend ♪
And we all see people pop up in Skid Row.
And they don't even know each other.
They walk around Skid Row
for one month or two months,
and say, what's up, OG?
What's up, one love?
And this, I calls them on
it, and most people don't.
And then they'll wonder why
your backpack gets stolen
or everything gets stolen.
Because you let a guy, a female or male,
show up and walk around for a month,
and you swear to god you know
'em cause they started saying,
what's up, one love?
What's up, OG?
But you didn't know this person,
and you allowed this
person to lay next to you,
hang out with you, and
then when you woke up,
all your stuff was gone.
See what I'm saying?
And then you went, well
why did he do that?
Because you did not know him or her.
And it was a setup from the gate.
A con artist is the most
vicious rattlesnake there is
because he or her, or his
job, is to lure you in,
to make you feel comfortable.
I mean, look, you're a big guy.
I'm a rough lookin' dude.
But do you, I don't have a
tattoo, I've never carried a gun
or carried a weapon,
never did a rob the city.
But when most people look at
me, they think I'm a rough guy,
bank robber, killer, molester,
drug seller, drug user,
and I've never done none of that.
And then the guys that
don't look as rough as me,
they think, he's a nice guy.
And that's the guy that's got
you for everything you wanted.
See, cause, my thing, if
there is a good and a evil,
if the devil wanted to get your soul,
he not gonna send some big guy like you
with all these muscles, somebody you'd be
nervous and scared of.
He gonna send a sweet, little,
old lady, or a little girl,
you could get, you'd let ya
come, let your guards down.
Like, did you, I don't know this movie,
you ever saw this movie where,
I think it was something about,
it might've been The Walking
Dead or something, right?
And they had this little girl
in there, little blonde girl.
And she was so cute and
sweet, and sat and smiled
at the guy, and she had no signs of being
one of the walking dead.
And she was just as beautiful
as you want, pretty.
And the guy walked up to her and said,
honey, are you all right?
And her mouth opened, turned
into a vicious monster
and bit him.
When he had got away,
one of the main fighters,
who had got away from all,
got lured in by the pretty little girl
cause they couldn't get him.
You know what I'm saying?
He was a good fighter, and
he saw 'em, he knew 'em,
he was whooping a lot of 'em.
It'd be 10, 20 of 'em coming
at him, and he'd whoop 'em all.
But this little girl,
this little pretty, sweet,
innocent girl made him smile, say, honey.
And he'd pick up and
say, are you all right?
And when he put her right here,
she turned into a monster
and bit the hell out of him.
So my point is when
people stress out in life,
they always like to point the finger.
Well, you did this and I
couldn't make my car payment
cause of you.
And so you blame them for
not making your car payment,
when it is you that made the
final decision when they say,
could you loan me that $150 to pay my,
I'll have it back by the
time your car payment due.
But when it wasn't there,
you wanna blame 'em.
But they didn't put a gun to your head
and make you do it, see?
And you don't never wait for the outcome
and listen to the whole story.
And you have to look at the
people you dealing with.
And the philosophy of
life is this, my friend.
If you go through life wantin' everything,
everything you see, a commercial.
Society, is not they fault.
It's a business.
They are bid to advertise
stuff on the TV, and you say,
I want it.
And you say I wanna do
this, I want babies.
I find that most people
want that American dream.
They want the white picket
fence, the house, the family,
the car, and they want to be
able to go out to the clubs
and have the nice little drinks
and the $10 and $20 drinks,
and live on Beverly Hills
where there's a nightclub
in the ghetto.
You wanna show it off for the homies.
I got the new Stacys on.
I'm driving a convertible BMW,
and the little girls waving,
their little and showing
their little butts
wearing that.
And you just eating it up.
And every time you see something,
most people wanna buy their Jordans
before they take care of their kids.
Most people wanna make their car payment
before they give their
woman, a guy have $1900,
he'll give his girl, here's
$40, go and buy something.
Go get yourself something nice.
And I asked one of my buddies when I say,
you ever been in Victoria's Secret?
Have you ever been in Bath and Body Works?
One bottle of lotion there costs you $25.
You got $1900, but you
will only give your wife
$30 or $40 of all $100 of it.
But you wanna go home and jump up and down
and have all this glorious,
lovely sex when she get drunk,
and all this.
You don't wanna make your
payments, and nothing like,
you don't wanna make your car payment.
Things you think that makes
you look good for society,
peer pressure.
I got the new Audi.
Look at my Volvo convertible.
You don't want the Chevy no more.
You want the convertible Mercedes now.
You want the Volvo and the Audi.
You want the Nissan.
A Ford is not good enough for you.
You want that beautiful,
new, brand new BMW
they just brought out.
The little sports one, they
got a nice little sports BMW,
look like a Ferrari or something.
And I looked at this thing
another day, I thought,
what is that?
About $300,000, $150,000 car?
And my buddy say, I'm
gonna get me one of them.
I looked at him, I say, you are?
What's wrong with the car you got?
I want that new BMW like Ferrari.
And you got the money for
that living in Skid Row?
Well, yeah, I got the money for it.
And I'm saying, what about your children
and your car payment and
your house and all that?
You got that kind of a job?
Well, no, nigger, I'm into
slaying some of this dope,
and I say, you gonna let
you think the government
gonna let you sling that dope
and not ask you for no receipts?
And what you gonna do, try to put it
in somebody else's name?
And see the government came and was
something on that one, too.
People will sell a lot of drugs and put,
I put it in your name,
and then they will go
to the sister or mother
and say, well, this is you?
You bought him this?
And that's your car out
there, and this is your house?
Can we see your receipts?
Cause if we catch you lying,
we gonna take everything from you, too.
And so, now, you done got
your family in trouble,
tryin' to undercut the government.
But you can't undercut the government
cause it's not about the government.
It's about society, living
in a function, able world.
And everybody's not gonna be rich.
It takes all sides of
life to make a world.
I don't drink or nothing,
but I'm homeless here.
Never had a day of school,
but to hear me speak sometime,
I have had people say,
you don't have no phone.
You don't go to the library.
You don't read no book.
You don't, you have no books.
You walk around Skid Row,
never been to school,
but we hear you speak,
where you get this kind of knowledge from?
Because I traveled, living
in different cultures.
And I paid attention to life.
See, we don't pay attention
to things around us.
So what I'm saying is that
when people say that they rich,
they wanna be rich, I say,
how you know you're not rich?
Cause you not rich in cash?
I mean, listen to the
way I speak, like I say.
There's no explanation for that.
I don't read books.
I don't carry phones and stuff.
And so people say, where
you get that knowledge at?
I say, cause I'm rich.
You rich in what?
I'm rich in knowledge.
Look at the man that's
got the $50 million,
but he got a pacemaker in his heart.
You know what I'm saying?
So look at me and you.
You up in age a little bit, too,
but when I pull my
shirt off, we got bodies
like we been working out all our lives.
You know what I'm saying?
And we, well, didn't I say, well, he say,
how you getting that knowledge?
Well, what other explanation could it be?
Everybody ain't never went to school,
cause you think somebody up there,
maybe it's god put it in me.
Maybe this is my richness.
I'm rich in knowledge and
understanding of life.
And to only understanding life,
all you got to do is live.
Because all we gonna do
is live on this planet,
and we can't take anything with us.
You can't put that BMW in that
casket and take it with you,
and even now, even now, we don't learn
from the past history.
Look at all the history.
Even kids sit up and wonder
when their parents gonna die,
when they get a big will in them.
Sometime you walk through the
house, not you personally,
but you see your daughter
or your son sitting there
staring at you.
And you'll say, what are you looking at?
Why're you staring at me like that?
And, nothing, nothing, I was just
thinking about something, Dad.
But in their mind, they saying,
they looking at you like,
Dad left me $10 million in that will.
He healthy, he ain't
gonna die soon at all.
That man running around
playing basketball,
and running all over
the world, mom, healthy.
So the Menendez brothers,
they want that money fast.
Kill the parents and then
say, well there are bills.
Well okay, that might be true,
but they're not here to tell us that now.
You killed them fore
they could tell us that,
afore we could investigate that.
And they thought the first
trial, they were going to,
they was a mistrial.
They thought, we got a mistrial,
and the court say okay.
The governor say, okay,
you got all that money,
and you got a mistrial.
Give 'em another trial, and take it all.
And now they got all the money,
and the Menendez brothers in prison cause
you cannot capitalize on a crime.
Look at Nicole Simpson and OJ Simpson.
Look at that used to play
Robert Blake, Baretta,
and his wife.
Had him on trial, they take
it he murdered as well.
Don't know if he ever
beat that one or not.
I didn't find out the outcome on that one.
But they had him on trial
for trying to kill his wife.
So money and things have
been the root of all evil.
Because most people, when
you a baby, you innocent.
Once you grow, your knowledge becomes.
Now you lookin' and you gotta learn.
Now that smile has turned
into a snake smile, yes.
Hey, how you doing, man, all right.
But they looking cause they want,
now they want that new car.
Now they want that big ass house.
Now they wanna sit up in
Beverly Hills and drink coffee
on Sunset, way out on
Sunset with the stars.
Because you got a decent job,
but you're really not a star.
But you wanna hang among those people
cause you're trying to make your come up,
like the billboard on Sunset
where Wilt Chamberlain
used to go there and have all sex with
all these different women,
but now he's dead, see?
And a lot of people saying,
how would you know about
the billboard on Sunset?
How would you know about
all the coffee shops
way up there on Sunset
with them rich people?
Cause I have went there
through there to see that.
Now, but when I was in
Miami, Florida, Miami Dade,
they got some of the most
beautiful beaches in the world.
And the sand is so snow
white, you could see
your feet in the water.
But the people in this
beautiful city is so, they not,
and this, they different from LA.
The people in Miami are so
naive to a lot of things,
so ignorant to a lot of things.
All they do is rob, steal
and kill over there.
That's all they do, rob, steal and kill.
Where here, they do a
lot of robbing, killing,
but it died down.
But they do is sell drugs here.
It's just the only thing
they know how to do.
And when we look at it, and
they say, why do you do that?
Cause that's only thing
I really know how to do,
and if you do know how to do something,
you done became so
comfortable with doing this
that you don't even
wanna enlighten yourself
to try to do anything else.
Cause you're lazy.
You wanna just stand out
there and sell dope now.
Going out there washing
cars, going out there,
going to work every day,
sitting in an office,
filling paper.
Ain't good enough for me.
I wanna be out there selling dope,
looking at the fat butt
girls and looking at
all the dudes, and life
is not cut up like that.
This world has to function
whether we like it or not.
And we can't point the finger and say,
I can't point the finger,
niggers, your fault
I ain't got no brothers and sisters.
It's your fault I ain't
got no wife and kids.
Sometimes, you have to say,
this is just the way life is.
Cause like I say, I'm no
better than anyone else.
I'm homeless right here in
Skid Row, sleep on the street.
And most people ask me
why I'm homeless cause
I don't do all the above.
Well, people, I probably
coulda went further in life,
but I did, I will not make an excuse.
I chose to be here because
I felt like if I had did
anything else, I would have stressed out
like the rest of people and
wouldna had any kind of feelings
or caring for the people.
I would have been caught
up in material stuff
and not care what anyone
else went through.
And sometime, I'm a little
hard on people because
I think they're a little
lazy, or they just rude,
but basically, I try
to keep a good attitude
and a good understanding of
life and I'm a not the thug
or the real mean, honorable
person that most people look at.
I don't know how I got that
look, but I do have that look,
but I have never, ever carried weapons
or did anything like that.
Until then, I hope everybody
have a good life, and remember,
love material things, but
don't get caught up in it
where it will control your life
cause everything goes and
comes, including your life.
Have a good day, people.